[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés marion
becker bonjour marion bonjour à vous
arrêt année pour ce tour de l'actualité
cette semaine nous recevons alain
joyandet bonjour je vous êtes donc
sénateurs les républicains de haute
saône à bienvenue à vous de la rue à
l'assemblée elle les députés ont examiné
la réforme ferroviaire des débats qui se
sont fait l'écho des inquiétudes
syndicales
ouverture à la concurrence au statut des
cheminots ont provoqué de vifs des
changes est député et sénateur préparent
leur riposte à la réforme des
institutions
le débat est lancé et l'opposition
prépare ses contre-propositions en
attendant l'examen de la réforme au
parlement
le mode de scrutin des européennes
valider le sénat a adopté mercredi le
projet de loi qui rétablit une
circonscription nationale unique aux
européennes il signe donc la fin des
huit circonscriptions et on commence
cette semaine avec l'assemblée nationale
qui examine la réforme ferroviaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est à l'origine des grèves des
manifestations des cheminots les députés
ont donc examiné la réforme ferroviaire
après avoir acté le changement de statut
de la sncf et l'ouverture à la
concurrence
ils ont notamment voté la fin du statut
de cheminot pour les nouvelles embauches
françois cheval pour ce dernier jour de
discussions l'heure est à la question du
tarif des billets et des droits des
voyageurs avec la prochaine ouverture à
la concurrence la france insoumise
propose de maintenir des points de vente
dans toutes les gares du territoire
entre 2011 et 2014 puis de 2000 emplois
ont été supprimés à la vente dans les
gares les boutiques les caisses et les
centres d'appels
nous nous opposons par cet amendement à
la politique de suppression des points
de vente et du tout numérique
les républicains eux s'opposent à cette
idée
je nourris certaines craintes face à cet
amendement je dois vous le dire
malheureusement dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de points de
vente physiques forcément partout ni
tout le temps si on en rajoute c'est des
emplois supplémentaires
je me pose la question de savoir qui va
les payer et si au final ça
n'engendrerait pas de nouveau un
renchérissement du coût du billet pour
les pour les usagers qui est pour et qui
est contre il n'est pas adoptée pas
adopter non plus l'idée des députés de
la république en marche de créer une
plate-forme commune pour l'achat de
billets partagé par tous les futurs
prestataires
al'inverse la proposition de la ministre
des transports de moduler les péages des
trains en fonction des trajets pour ne
pas déstabiliser les petites lignes est
votée mais la fin de l'examen du texte
promet au moins une surprise
l'amendement de la nouvelle gauche qui
prévoit de supprimer les locomotives
diesel trouve un écho favorable du
gouvernement
il ya une perspective qui est celle de
2040 qui n'a pas été choisi au hasard
qu'ils aient la même perspective qui
figure dans le plan national climat
portée par le ministre la transition
écologique et solidaire qui lui
s'intéresse
il a bien raison aux voitures diesel
mais je pense qu'il faut s'intéresser
aux locomotives diesel cet objectif sera
satisfait dans le cadre de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités et de sa
trajectoire de verdissement des flottes
mais à ce stade moi je donne aussi un
avis favorable soit amendement qui est
pour les neuf articles du projet de loi
seront soumis au vote par scrutin public
mardi prochain alain joyandet il ya
beaucoup de choses qui devrait vous
satisfaire dans cette réforme est ce que
vous l'avez très haut je pense est une
réforme utile ne va pas assez loin les
sans doute à mi-chemin par rapport à ce
que nous aurions besoin de faire mais on
peut pas on peut pas laisser les choses
en l'état
voilà donc mais c'est la sncf c'est une
grande histoire et je pense qu'il
faudrait quand même réussir à trouver un
équilibre entre l'ouverture à la
concurrence d'une part puisque ça me
paraît bon mais en même temps ne pas
tout casser du service public
j'ai noté l'aide le débat sur sur le
maintien des points dans les territoires
et c'est ce que je crains ce que je
crains c'est d'aller vers une
libéralisation certes utile mais
kick-ass en même temps le service public
on a vraiment besoin dans les
territoires je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
on a besoin dans les territoires de
maintenir de la vie et nos concitoyens
attendent cela parlait mais vous la
vôtre et bien non on va voir on va voir
ce que comment le texte va évoluer pour
l'instant je suis plutôt favorable
en gros favorable à cette réforme et
vous savez que le sénat apporte toujours
des modifications je pense qu'on l'a
votre avis je la voterai sans doute
modifié par le sénat vous lisiez à
l'instant cette question des territoires
vous craignez une désertification
ferroviaire je crains c'est même pas que
je crains c'est que je constate sur le
territoire j'ai entendu
emmanuel macron dire y'a pas de problème
avec les territoires ruraux
je pense qu'il n'a pas la conscience de
ce qui se passe on a aujourd'hui une
fracture territoriale énorme sur plein
de sujets toutes les réformes qui nous
ont été annoncés depuis quelques mois
annoncé parce que on annonce beaucoup de
choses on attend les choses veniez de on
l'est on veut les voir venir au
parlement mais mais mais tout ça va dans
le sens d'une augmentation la fracture
territoriale un sentiment tout est fait
pour les grandes
les grandes agglomérations les
territoires ruraux un vrai problème on
fait plus de route on a annoncé la fin
des grands travaux
o les régions qui vont gérer à l'avenir
ces lignes ce sont des élus à la tête de
ces régions anti l'intérêt finalement à
supprimer des lignes
oui mais vous savez bien aussi que quand
on dit c'est les régions qui vont
financer la proximité ça veut dire que
c'est avec les impôts de ceux qui sont
dans les régions il ya quand même un
état et l état français comme une
péréquation
on peut pas dire tout ce qui est grand
tout ce qui est rentable tout ce qui est
l'avenir ça va être l'état et puis la
pénurie va être gérés par les régions et
donc payés directement par les
contribuables de ces régions le
contribuable en région ne peut pas tout
se payer alors qu'au niveau national il
y aurait une péréquation c'est un vrai
sujet de fracture territoriale et c'est
contre ça aussi que je vais me battre
dans le cadre de la réforme de la sncf
sur ce dossier des petites lignes est
assez décharger sur la collectivité
complément mais pas que sur les petites
lignes
écoutez pour l'instant les départements
les régions sont appelées à financer des
compétences que l'état abandonne et en
plus en plus on leur demande de ne pas
augmenter leurs dépenses de plus de 1%
par an pendant pendant cinq ans il ya un
malaise terrible entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales dans ma
région je suis président la commission
des finances de la région bourgogne
franche comté
je vois bien de près les transferts qui
sont opérés par l'état
l'état qui prend plus rien en charge y
compris sur les questions de santé
savais pas ce qu'il faut être concret le
prs le plan régional de santé en
bourgogne franche comté vient d'être
retoqué à l'unanimité y compris de ceux
qui ont appelé à voter pour monsieur
macron ce plan vient d'être retoqué à
l'unanimité il y a quelques jours parce
qu'évidemment la priorité de l'état
c'est pas la santé contrairement aussi à
ce que dit le président la santé n'est
plus une priorité quand vous parlez des
des petites gares des petites lignes
il faut parler aussi des petits hôpitaux
des services d'urgence il ya un vrai
problème avec les services d'urgence
dans la ruralité et ça c'est un sujet
majeur quand on dit reconstruire la
france s'est reconstruit la france des
territoires pour qu'il ya une vie dans
les territoires pour les pour les jeunes
dans les territoires et d'un mot face au
mouvement social vous avez entendu
emmanuel macron il tient le cap de la
fermeté at il raison ça dépend ce qu'on
entend par fermeté parce que je pense
qu'il faut il faut être ferme et faut
pas être obtus je pense qu'il ya un
hiatus dans
que monsieur macron incompris de son
élection quand il dit je fais ce que je
dis très bien et fait ce qu'il dit mais
il faut quand même toujours se rappeler
qu'ils 24 % de français qui ont voté
pour lui au premier tour et au deuxième
tour il n'a pas été élu pour ce qu'il a
proposé
il a été élu contre madame le pen donc
par rapport à ça il faut pas se dire je
fais toute la politique que j'avais
annoncé avant le premier tour il faut
faire une politique qui rassemble
l'ancien sur cette réforme phare vient
pour l'encourager à tenir bon
je pense qu'il faut il faut aller au
bout de la réforme parce que de toute
façon si le gouvernement art était en
cours je pense que pour notre pays ce
serait une catastrophe pour les ré les
réformes à venir
ça veut pas dire que je bénis
complètement la réforme et à partir du
moment où on est engagé dans une réforme
et qu'on considère qu'elle est bonne
pour le pays soit les pas bonne il faut
l'arrêter soient les bonnes et il faut
essayer d'aller au bout
allez autre réforme celle des
institutions l'opposition prépare sa
riposte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine au sénat le groupe
socialiste lancé une plateforme
numérique de consultation et présenter
ses propositions
votre groupe alain joyandet les
républicains ne pense pas voter cette
réforme l'opposition prépare sa
contre-attaqué parmi les sujets
d'inquiétude la représentation des
territoires 30% de parlementaires en
moins ce sont autant de circonscriptions
remaniée a grandi depuis six ans pierre
morel à l'huissier est déjà le seul
député de la lozère il faut trois heures
pour traverser son département ce qu'il
oblige à tenir un planning serré se
regarder ce reportage aurélie darblade
et sophie béchir l'ont suivi le temps
d'une journée de l'aubrac aux cévennes
des causses à la margeride chaque mois
pierre morel à l'huissier sillonne les
routes des cinq microrégion de la lozère
dans son véhicule acheté il ya moins
d'un mois il a déjà parcouru 3200 84km
jeu sur budget d'être partout j'ai eu
repas le samedi 8 repas repas
manifestation le dimanche
mais c'est aussi
une diversité de dinde approche et c'est
ça l'intérêt aussi de de pouvoir
représenter l'intégralité d'un
département car depuis six ans pierre
morel à l'huissier le seul député de la
lozère
chaque mois ils parcourent 7000
kilomètres pour couvrir sa
circonscription
ce matin il vient rencontrer le gérant
de cette société de pneumatiques qui
n'arrive pas à vendre son exploitation
70 ans et je continue pour être à
l'écouté de tous ses administrés
le député s'imposant planning serré déjà
il doit repartir à quelques kilomètres
de là il retrouve pour le déjeuner des
élus locaux des artisans et l'un d'eux
s'est attaché parlementaire
l'attaché parlementaire c'est une c'est
une race importante comment on va passer
à 380 ou 400 députés
on allait on aura des attachés
parlementaires à plus consistants +13
fortifiée plus fortifiée mais surtout
plus nombreux car si pierre morel à
l'huissier est favorable à la réduction
du nombre de députés
ce n'est pas sans conditions on peut pas
avoir que trois ou quatre que leurs
auteurs il en faut 6 7 8 voire 9
il faut être bien entouré et puis je
pense qu'il faut revoir toute la machine
législative c'est-à-dire que le
parlementaire fasse plus de contrôle
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
peut-être un peu moins de la loi un peu
peut-être un peu moins de 2 logorrhée
dans l'assemblée la réforme des
institutions ne permettra peut-être pas
à pierre morel à l'huissier d'effectuer
un cinquième mandat
en revanche la lozère ne devraient pas
être touchés par ces changements
le département le moins peuplé de france
conservera un député un sénateur alain
joyandet faut-il inscrire dans la
constitution cette représentation des
territoires
un sénateur ou un député par département
je crois que c'est le minimum
autrement on est on est plus dans le
bicamérisme et on n'est plus dans
l'unité nationale donc sur la question
de la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires je ne peux pas m'y
opposer
j'ai toujours été favorable et lorsque
j'étais
gouvernement avec nicolas sarkozy nous
en parlions déjà
donc je pense qu'il faut faire la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
jeudi
je les exprime son désaccord total sur
la réduction de 30% du nombre de
parlementaires
oui mais bon moi je vous dis ce que je
pense je pense que gérard larcher a une
position d'ailleurs qui est une position
très remarquée sur la question de la
constitution fait un très gros travail
de de concertation avec la présidence de
la république
et d'ailleurs je pense que grâce au
sénat et grâce à lui lorsqu'on va avoir
une fille née une réforme qui sera
peut-être un peu moins brutale voilà
juste justement pour essayer de
conserver c'est le rôle du sénat de
conserver une représentation
territoriale qui soit la plus juste la
plus équilibrée possible je pense pas
que gérard larcher soit totalement
opposé à la baisse du nombre de
parlementaires après c'est une
discussion sur combien on enlève deux
parlementaires pour que justement on
puisse garder la représentation dans les
territoires parce que ceux qui nous
écoutent doivent savoir que nous avons
aussi des règles constitutionnelles et
que par rapport au nombre d'habitants
des départements par rapport au nombre
de parlementaires
on ne peut pas s'écarter on peut passer
on peut pas dire on va prendre deux
députés ou de sénateurs joe jonas à qui
on va en mettre deux de plus sans la
dans la ruralité c'est pas aussi simple
il ya des règles constitutionnelles de
représentativité et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut faire attention
réduire oui mais à un niveau qui
permette justement un député et un
sénateur au minimum par département
quelle est la ligne officielle de votre
groupe au sénat
on sent tout de même quelques quelques
10 tensions entre bruno retailleau et
gérard larcher sur cette réforme
cela constitue comme toujours au sénat
nous avons des discussions qui ont
débuté des discussions très concrète
très objective entre les uns les autres
et un respect des positions des uns et
des autres et puis in fine et nous nous
mettons d'accord sur une position
commune vous pouvez remarquer que en
général sur les grands textes y compris
d'ailleurs souvent sur les petits textes
le groupe au sénat sous la présidence de
bruno retailleau évidemment dans la
ligne de gérard larcher au
obtient toujours un consensus et on a un
vote en général très très majoritaire de
notre groupe vous pensez qu'un accord
avec le sénat est encore possible sur
cette réforme des institutions
il ya des lignes rouges qu'il faut pas
franchir il ya la question de la
proportionnelle c'est pas que les de la
question parce que les députés le nombre
de députés sénateurs c'est l'arbre qui
cache la forêt je rappelle aussi à ceux
qui nous écoutent que pour faire cela il
n'y a pas besoin de réformer la
constitution pour diminuer le nombre de
sénateurs et de députés une loi simple
suffit
mais comme il ya trois textes dont
qu'ils sont ensemble loi simple loi
organique et réforme de la constitution
on a demandé à voir tout parce qu'on va
pas dire oui à la constitution sans
savoir ce qu'il ya dans les autres lois
savez on n'est plus des perdreaux du
matin quand même on sait comment ça se
passe et donc on a demandé de voir
l'ensemble avoir un accord sur
l'ensemble ça paraît difficile mais je
pense qu'on a encore la possibilité de
discuter la question du nombre pour
garder une présence dans l'est dans les
territoires et puis à 7 cette affaire de
proportionnelle je ne comprends pas les
15%
je comprends pas les 15% parce que ou
bien c'est bon la proportionnelle où
quelqu'un il faut mettre 50 % à 60 % ou
c'est pas bon il faut pas en mettre donc
vous voyez on est dans un petit sac il a
essayé de contenter tout le monde
philippe et le modem sont alliés qui ne
pensent qu'il se contente pas tout le
monde il essaie d'appliquer avec le
président de la république l'accord
qu'ils ont passés avec monsieur bayrou
au moment des élections en monsieur
bayrou est pas content parce qu'il
trouve qu'elle n'a pas assez
et puis ceux qui sont contre la
proportionnelle trouve que parce que ces
députés qui vont être élus à la
proportionnelle
ils vont être d'une certaine façon très
différents de ceux qui seront élus sur
les territoires et c'est peut-être à
cause de ce nombre
élu à la proportionnelle qu'on va
peut-être pas pouvoir garder dans chacun
des départements au moins un député
j'espère que j'espère qu'on pourra le
faire quand même mais je ne comprends
pas ce chiffre de 15% alors peut-être
que c'est dû en même temps une fois de
plus mais je pense que pour les
institutions il faut pas faire du en
même temps c'est la france les
institutions et pour la france il faut
faire ce qui est bon ce qui est pas bon
il faut pas le faire au menu du ces de
la séance au sénat cette semaine alain
joyandet les élections européennes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après l'assemblée nationale le sénat a
adopté à son tour la mise en place d'une
circonscription unique pour les
prochaines élections européennes qui
auront lieu en mai 2010 neuf fini les
huit circonscriptions régionales en
vigueur depuis 2004
pour le gouvernement c'est un moyen de
favoriser la participation à cette
élection peu mobilisatrice
mais la droite n'est pas favorable samia
déchire ce sont les élections qui
mobilise le moins les français depuis le
premier scrutin européen de 1979
le taux de participation n'a cessé de
baisser moins d'un électeur sur deux
fait le déplacement pour tenter d'y
intéresser davantage les français
le gouvernement veut remplacer les huit
grandes circonscriptions inter-régional
par une circonscription unique un projet
de loi soutenue au sénat par les
centristes les radicaux et les
socialistes
j'ai demandé dans les mairies est ce que
vous pouvez me citer un nom d'un de nos
députés européens
j'ai constaté pour l'immense majorité
des citoyens et même des s'est vue ils
sont inconnus
c'est certainement plus clair d'avoir
une circonscription unique plutôt que
des circonscriptions complètement
artificielle qui ne repose sur rien les
électeurs aurez donc le choix entre des
listes nationales une pour chaque partie
la droite sénatoriale craint que ces
futurs élus européens soient trop
éloignés des territoires elle s'est
opposée au projet en enlevant le seul
point d'ancrage territorial pour
constituer la circonscription
multirégional on va encore aggraver le
phénomène avait des des élus hors sol
qu'ils n'auront au plus aucun ancrage
territorial et qui donneront la toute
puissance aux partis politiques pour
choisir leur candidat
la droite il vous est aussi un moyen
pour le jeune parti la république en
marche de contourner son faible maillage
territorial sur 27 pays membres de
l'union européenne
23 et liste aujourd'hui leurs députés
européens sur des listes nationales
joyandet pourquoi vous opposez à cette
circonscription unique qu'est ce que
vous craignez le débat national sur
cette question européenne
d'abord je ne m'y oppose pas parce que
j'y suis favorable les républicains en
tout cas il fait partie
on a notre indépendance d'esprit comme
un fait partie n'y est pas favorable
seront évoqués commençaient par en tout
cas sur ce sujet là j'ai moi j'ai
personnellement j'y suis favorable
pourquoi j'y suis favorable
j'essaie d'être le plus cohérent
possible quand on est élu d'un canton on
est élu par les gens du canton quand on
est élu de la région m'ont élu pour les
gens de par les gens de la région
et quand on est élu de la france pour
aller à l'europe et bien on est élu par
part par la france entière
on pourrait imaginer un autre scénario
qui serait d'ailleurs à peu près y est
pas identique en terme d'élections mais
vous pourriez imaginer présence sur les
assemblée et sénat et l'assemblée
nationale qui envoie à l'europe ce rêve
serait beaucoup de sens comme le font
les communes qui envoie des
représentants dans les intercommunalités
le fait que ce soit des élus français
pour toute la france d'ailleurs au
passage
est ce que les députés européens
sortants ont été je pense du tout être
10 convenant leur égard mais est ce que
est ce que est ce que les français
savent aujourd'hui qu'elle qu'elle est
vraiment le député européen qui incarne
la région donc je pense que cette
position de laurent wauquiez et d'une
grande partie de la droite
je pense qu'on a on a un parti si vous
voulez qu'il ya des positions
majoritaire et puis dans certains cas je
pense que un parlementaire
voilà j'ai été membre du gouvernement en
plus pour les affaires étrangères
donc je vois bien quand même hein j'ai
beaucoup regardé ce qui se passait sur
un certain nombre de sujets on peut
avoir une position personnelle sans
fenêtre on pour autant en désaccord avec
laurent que est une erreur je soutiens
c'est une erreur de laurent wauquiez de
défendre cet ancrage local pour des
élections européennes
non parce que je pense qu'il est
présidente de région aussi il a tenu
aussi une vision de aussi une vision des
choses bon voilà je n'ai pas on ne
défend pas une région
ben justement c'est pour ça que je si si
on était si on était dans l'esprit des
allemands avec des grandes régions fort
des länder est certain que du coup on
dise vraiment le député européen va
aller à bruxelles ou à strasbourg pour
défendre sa région mais vous voyez bien
que pour l'europe fonctionne matic des
divergences qu'il existe au sein des
leurs sur cette question open c'est pas
ce point divergent si vous laissez
simplement je pense que j'ai pas
beaucoup de franchement j'ai très peu de
divergences avec le révoquer sur
l'europe
je partage vraiment pratiquement
l'ensemble de sa vision pour l'europe si
on peut en dire un mot
je pense qu'entre les nationalistes
incarné par les extrêmes et puis les
mondialistes incarné par le président de
la république je pense qu'on a vraiment
nous quelque chose à faire il faut il
faut être européen certes mais une
nouvelle europe refaire l'europe et pour
cela je suis totalement aux côtés de
laurent wauquiez sur la question de la
circonscription alors qu'on fasse des
circonscriptions régionales ou d une
circonscription nationale c'est pas le
fond du problème
l essentiel c par l'essentiel c'est très
accessoire et pour le coup pour le coup
il se trouve que je suis plus favorable
à une circonscription nationale
d'ailleurs vous savez elle peut
peut-être éventuellement cette
circonscription nationale ne pas nous
être totalement défavorable aux
républicains on en reparlera allez c'est
l'heure de faire le tour de l'actualité
politique avec notre partenaire
politique du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dimanche à ses bons jours - c'est tour
de l'actualité
bonjour alain joyandet marchon emmanuel
macron été sur tf1 jeudi pour répondre
aux inquiétudes des français
il s'est livré à une sorte d'opération
de calinothérapie à l'égard des
retraités et des cheminots tout en
conservant une certaine fermeté ans
hurlait sur les réformes
c'est quoi macron c'est main de fer dans
un gant de velours c'est un peu ça
l'idée
je pense que c'est surtout de plus en
plus c'est comme ça que je ressent sur
le terrain c'est comme ça que je
longtemps sur le terrain
je pense que c'est de plus en plus une
illusion parce qu'il ya eu je pense une
arrivée comme il l'a dit lui même un peu
par effraction à la suite de
l'instrumentalisation des des affaires
qui ont fait que la droite a perdu cette
élection qui était imperdable je pense
pas que ce soit nos idées qu'ils aient
perdu ce sont c'est le contexte qui a
qui a fait perdre et du coup voilà
aujourd'hui on est en train de de faire
l'addition de 1 an de gouvernement avec
de très très grande disparité entre ce
qu'il dit est ce que l'on ressent sur le
terrain la liste est très longue y
compris pendant l'interview textures sur
les réformes quand même il les enchaîne
il les tient il les fesses et je vais
prendre un exemple concret il il n'y a
pas de ya pas de problème avec la
ruralité on ouvre des classes en plus
oui sauf que l'on ferme 808 classe le
solde entre ce qu'on ouvrait ce qu'on
ferme c'est moins 808 sait pas plus
quelque chose sur la question des
djihadistes par exemple on va être très
très ferme
sauf qu' aucune mesure ferme n'est prise
et on compte no more attentats après
attentats on pleure mais qu'est ce qui
se passe derrière il se passe pas grand
chose donc sur tf1 vous l'avez pas
trouvé convaincant notamment il a
remercié à plusieurs reprises
les retraités est ce que c'est je veux
pas dire que je n'ai pas trouvé
convaincant c'est un homme c'est un
homme de communication c'est un homme de
médias je pense que il a fait sur la
forme
vous parlez de câlinothérapie c'est un
exercice de communication plutôt réussie
ration séduction c'est un exercice
plutôt réussie sur le plan de la
communication
mais sur le fond des choses demandées
aux retraités ce qu'il pense il dit je
remercie les retraités
franchement un président qui remercie
une catégorie sociale pour sa
contribution
j'avais encore jamais trop entendu cela
à quoi donc on sent on sent quelque
chose en ce moment fessée c'est un
ressenti tout à fait objectif ô je sais
je suis pas un opposant permanent jeu
plutôt je suis encore de le montrer
je plutôt quelqu'un qui souligne les
bonnes choses et je demande depuis très
longtemps je suis chef d'entreprise
demande depuis très longtemps
le fameux cic qui était une ânerie soit
converti en baisse de charges pérennes
il le fait c'est très bien il ya un
certain nombre de choses pour les
entreprises et pour les gens très riches
qui sont bonnes ça je le conteste pas
mais pour le reste des millions de gens
qui sont inquiets pour leur avenir
je regarde sur le terrain et je constate
qu'entre une belle émission sur tf1
est ce que les gens vivent sur le
terrain ça risque d'être un boomerang
parce qu'ils se disent mais qu'est ce
qu'ils nous disent président sur la
question des 80 km art il a lâché un peu
de lest bon à peu de frais mais est-ce
que vous pensez que ça peut changer son
image un peu de présidents des villes où
est ce que vous vous réclamez toujours
l'annulation pure et simple de la mesure
un mot d'abord je n'ai jamais demandé
l'annulation d'une partie mais mon parti
non plus mon parti non plus je pense
qu'on ait beaucoup des faits n'ont pas
cédé au sénat ont lancé une pétition au
sénat notamment mon collègue michel
raison sénateur de la haute saône
conduit un groupe de travail on demande
pas la suppression totale on en la
subsidiarité
on demande en demande un peu de bon sens
dans mon département en haute saône
il ya des endroits 80 km heure n'a aucun
sens à la hausse et à la baisse ont
certains endroits c'est impossible de
rouler à 80 km/heure il faudrait dire 40
ou 50 vous savez dans le léon les vosges
saônoises venait en haute-saône vous
allez voir ce merveilleux département et
vous verrez que dire 80 km heure partout
ça n'a pas de sens que moi je demande
pas l'annulation de la mesure
jeudi la subsidiarité on a des préfets
je milite aussi pour une chose
décentralisant l'état sur le registre
de l'as des as 10 t des universités il a
il a affiché une certaine fermeté est ce
que ça vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
chose quand même 7 ce oui bien sûr je
pense qu'il faut faire respecter la loi
ce qui est dommage parce que je sais ce
que je regrette c'est qu'elle n'ait pas
été respectée au début parce que
l'aéroport en question il a été il a été
confirmée par toutes les décisions de
justice ont il a pris la décision
d'arrêter ce projet je pense que c'est
une très mauvaise chose pour l'avenir
pour tous les autres projets qu'on
voudra avoir en france savait quand on
parle de reconstruire la france
pourquoi ça marche en avant en france
faut garder aussi du bon sens on faisait
des routes on sait du bâtiment il se
passe plus rien dans les départements
dans les régions connerré comme les
notes il ya plus de grands chantiers et
sur celle ci c'est le mot de la fin
alors autres invitations politique par
des sans terre merci à vous de gym et
merci à vous aurez alors si marion la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]